die laufen rum gibt skandieren die haben
häuser die mit fahnen dekorierten nummer
denkt man wäre ein paar jahrzehnte
zurück und das erschreckt und das ist
hier die emscherstraße 2 das sind also
die beiden häuser die ich hier
ausschließlich von nationalsozialisten
beruhen und sie erreichen mit
demonstrationen das ist nicht wie früher
man traf sich in der kneipe unter der
fahne und hatte da parolen raus sondern
heute trifft man man man organisiert
sich um einzelne menschen rum das sind
einzelne tüten oder figuren oder führer
von mir ist auch die dann leute anzieht
ich habe die äußerungen ungefähr dass
inhalt ist jude 2.0 gehört ich bitte
äußerungen dieser art zu unterlassen